oh my god I need backup guys alright
guys so it is training day for about
Phil five head of the live stream today
isn't about winning though alright we've
just got to focus up try it and get as
good as we can ahead a live stream so we
can beat the viewers and do as well as
we can so I think first we need to
decide what everyone's gonna be alright
Erin you're the assault Andrus you're
also an assault by want using a rifle
and then will your the support right I'm
also gonna give you some a load of tips
whilst we're playing all right I want
you to be using gunfire think about how
you're shooting your gun also squad
revives are key and watch out for squad
leader commands because that's going to
allow us to work as a squad you ready oh
crap here I've gone in I mean guys I
need backup guys just left our squad I
need backup how do I get back out so so
scared that you're in there by yourself
okay so head over to the aerodrome this
is gonna get better for ya that's a
little group up now okay so we're gonna
be doing a we're gonna need to be moved
quickly to push through so if everyone
follows me alright and head over right
yeah right squad roll out oh right in
front of me right in front of you just
got that's not who just like Erin saving
my back cuz I got me was it useless I
know it's one of you save me I'm gonna
mark babe we're gonna defend bait so
squad order is this defending base if we
hold here oh I just got killed by
grenade I would not advise going down
the corner unless you go around spraying
your gun yeah I'm about oh my god ha all
ours got white and who would you most
rather having the trenches with him he
was in the menu for 20 minutes that's a
lie he was in the menu
yep that's cuz I was dead so who would
you rather someone who's in the trenches
nobody's doing nothing the whole time
but I think I mean I don't know I didn't
keep count but you lost count
yeah I don't know we both died a few
times
I shot someone support oh you said and
Ross be fair the one thing I will say is
it's nice everyone sticking together as
a squad also that's that's one big thing
when we would drop down there a do you
notice no one picked up the revives
white squad revived Oh Oh Jim Jim Jim
Jim Jim
you down but don't worry squad revived
picking you up hold left trigger hold
left trigger and us all right someone's
mushy humping him anyway right
me here would you not and Ross he's made
it clear that he's not trying to help
anyone else then he dies anyway but my
aims all fall on my ground so one thing
you might want to do is burst fire see
when we talk about tactical finds don't
just hold the trigger down like
borrowing like three or four bullet
bursts okay a lot more accurate if you
guys look at my scream now what I'll do
when I'm trying to hit someone
cuz I'll go like that and then I'll stop
yeah because then you kind of control it
and it'll recenter okay alright so let's
head over to a anyway you're gonna get
that tank you don't stay alive nice what
advice can you give see both wolf and
and Ross to kind of get more kills keep
paper
what the hell be patient that it kills
come to you I've come back out as oh wow
that's what I feel that is a good place
and we just got hit by a v1 rocket sorry
it's a little bit of a feedback session
alright how do you guys think you did if
I heard a lot of talk on my left ear but
I didn't see many kills on the screen
I've got a little fact for you because I
had a little peek at the school board I
think this is gonna make will happen
actually
we've actually had the most killers I
know he had nine kills you an egg sack
no no you must a fire program right I'm
okay it back you got you've got eight
kills all right you've got eight kills
pretty good well that was a lot of fun
I'm excited to see how much we improve
come December on the live stream on
Sport Bible make sure to follow the page
so you don't miss it it's gonna be a lot
of fun
[Music]